- Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Manila, Philippines,
and for lunch today I am eating
at a Filipino roadside restaurant.
This is one of the restaurants
that I am most looking
forward to eating at.
This place is on the corner of the road.
There's a mechanic's
shop kind of surrounding.
It's a great environment,
and the Filipino food they serve here
looks absolutely incredible.
(lively music)
Hello, hello.
What is your name?
- Martina.
- [Mark] Martina.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- [Mark] How old are you?
Four.
(sizzling)
(chopping)
Can I have leimpo, two.
There were so many restaurants
I was looking forward
to eating at in Manila
but the legendary Aling
Sosing's Carinderia,
located on the corner of
a neighborhood street,
shaded by a giant mango tree
with an impressive array of Filipino food
was a local spot I couldn't wait to try.
Like most carinderias, or
local Filipino food restaurants
in the Philippines, to order,
all you have to do is walk
up to the front of the stall,
check out all the glorious
dishes in front of you,
and pick and choose whatever you like.
- One tilapia?
- And one tilapia, yes please.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, squid, can I have squid also.
And also this, and also
one plate of this one.
Pok med, yes.
Okay, and two rice.
The most challenging part
is not ordering everything you see.
Oh yeah, Mike is looking at all that food.
Michael, look at all that food.
I had read that this was place
would get just absolutely
jam packed at lunch time,
so luckily Jing and I
came right at 11 a.m.
We arrived here there were tables open
but right now as we sat down
it's completely full,
there no more tables left.
People are gonna start waiting
and it's not even lunchtime
yet, it's just 11 a.m.
It is a carinderia-style restaurant.
It's a local Filipino food restaurant,
and you walk up to the front,
they have all of the dishes prepared,
all of the different stews,
and all of the different
common, typical Filipino dishes,
and then they also are known
for their grilled tilapia,
and they're also known for
their inihaw na liempo,
which is the grilled pork belly.
So, this is one of those restaurants
where you could just stand up there
and pick and choose so many dishes,
and it's hard to know when to stop
because you wanna eat it all.
This is also a great time
to come to this restaurant
because you see all the
dishes are prepared.
And another thing I read
about this restaurant
is that they don't recook any more food,
or they don't cook any more dishes,
so once that dish is
gone, you're out of luck,
they won't have it again
for the rest of the day.
I gotta start with the signature dish
which is their grilled pork.
They have it all in
just slabs of pork belly
that they grill like that
but then when you order it
they chop it up into bite-sized pieces.
Big bite-sized pieces,
and you can see the, oh,
that's the skin right there,
that chewy skin.
Well, I think I'm just gonna
go in with my fingers for this.
I want to get a piece for my first bite
that includes all layers of the belly.
Oh yeah, you can see the skin, the fat,
and immediately I can feel the
juices coming onto my fingers
when I pick that up.
It's so smokey,
and then the meat is tender
but then the skin is pretty rubbery
but that's all part of
the textural experience.
Next up I'm gonna try the fish
but I think I'm gonna make my sauce first
with calamansi and chilis.
I think this might be soy sauce.
I'm going to go for the soy sauce
and then I'm going to add
this to my chili bowl.
And then squeeze in the calamansi.
Oh yeah.
This is the sauce of champions,
and then just kind of mash
up this chili a little bit.
I'm definitely gonna ask
them for some more chilis.
Actually at the front there
they had a whole panful of chilis,
so I think you can maybe go up there
and self-serve yourself.
Alright, that's gonna
be perfect for the fish.
Okay, grilled tilapia here.
Oh, that feels nice and soft.
Oh, you can see how juicy it is too there.
Oh, wonderful
and I gotta go in for some of that chili
and that soy sauce and goodness.
Oh, look at that bite.
Oh, no I lost the chili.
The chili fell over.
Okay, I'll scoop that back into my spoon.
Oh, that tilapia is so nice and juicy
and it has a nice smokey flavor,
and then just that simple
sauce, the soy sauce
with the citrus-y calamansi,
and the calamansi has a flavor that's,
I think it's somewhere
halfway in-between an orange
and a lemon.
Maybe it has like little
bit of a sweet tinge to it
compared to a lime or a lemon
but it still has that nice
sour, citrus-y flavor.
It's just a simple sauce combination
that you can basically
eat with everything.
This is a Filipino dish
that I think it's eggplant, there's okra,
there are long beans, and
there's bitter melon as well,
and if I remember correctly
this dish there's some shrimp paste
or some krill paste that
gives it its flavor.
So, I will dig into some,
oh, and I think we might
have some fried pork in here
that gives it its flavor too.
Put this onto my rice.
Oh, that's awesome.
It has a really nice garlic-y taste to it.
That's really garlic-y and then you have,
I did get a piece of
like crispy pork belly
I think in that bite.
And that pumpkin is amazing.
It's not like mushy at all.
It's kind of like, or maybe it's a squash
because it has a very silky texture to it,
rather than being that like
kind of mushy, dry texture.
That's delicious.
I gotta take one more bite of that.
Extraordinary actually, extraordinary.
And I'm gonna follow that
with some of this soup.
Oh, wow.
I was actually expecting
it to be plainer than that.
Oh, that's really good.
A little bit sour,
and it has a very meaty broth taste to it,
and yet it's not too salty,
and the next dish I ordered is kaldereta,
and this is another
well-known Filipino dish
but this is like a stew.
Put this onto my rice.
Let me get a little
bit more of that sauce.
Oh, I love that sour taste to it.
Kind of rich, kind of oily
stew with a sour taste,
and then that meat is so tender.
That'll be really good with a chili on it.
As soon as you bite into that chili
that's just an eruption of chili.
Oh, that makes, oh yeah,
I'm a little bit of a chili addict
but that tastes really, really good.
And next I've got a squid dish.
Oh, a leaf has fallen into the squid.
Yeah, and I think it's
black ink with the squid.
Let me just taste one of
the little heads actually.
Put this onto my rice,
and oh, I'm gonna add a little
bit more of that squid sauce.
Oh, look at that darkness.
That's very sweet
and a little sour and salty.
It almost tastes like
sweet and sour squid.
And then the squid is very tender
but it almost has like, you can sense
that it has like a
little bit of rubberiness
underneath the tenderness.
So, how they've cooked it,
it's very nice and tender.
- How's the food?
- Awesome, man, very, very good.
We just ordered some of
these grilled pork skewers,
pork barbecue.
Oh, look at that.
That looks wonderful.
Okay, let me reach into
this pork barbecue.
They've just really packed on the meat
onto this skewer and then
there's a piece of fat
at the end here.
Oh, that's right off the grill.
Oh, that is just ridiculously tender
without being too tender.
Oh, and that almost has like a little bit
of a sweet barbecue sauce to it.
We didn't order this at first
bu then Ying said we should order this,
so I'm glad we got it.
The texture of that meat.
Thank you, thank you very
much, the food is so good.
Hello.
How are you?
Nice to meet you.
What's your name?
- Jason.
- Kaldereta.
- Margherita.
Nice to meet you, man.
(lively music)
Thank you, okay.
Oh yeah.
Now we're talking.
Okay.
Now we can do some serious chili eating.
Oh yes.
- Wanna soup?
- Oh yes, please, thank you.
Oh, hot fresh soup.
Is it beef?
Okay, thank you.
Okay, I gotta take a.
Oh.
Oh, that's so hot.
Oh yeah, it is so rich.
Put some of this over the fish.
Oh yeah.
And a chili.
That completes the trio of flavors.
Oh, and that's wonderful.
(talks in foreign language)
- $640.
- Thank you very much.
Sarap.
Lots of people are coming here
for the amazing food
and so we just finished our meal
and then we got up off the table
'cause people were waiting for our table,
so now I'm just standing around
just enjoying the aromas from the food
and from the grill
and just this awesome, awesome
atmosphere here in Manila.
And yeah, if you're looking
for some properly good
local Filipino food in Manila,
this is a carinderia,
a local Filipino food restaurant
that you don't want to miss.
The grilled dishes are good,
all the different dishes
that you can pick and
choose from at the front
are good, the owners are really friendly.
This is another restaurant
that just has it all.
Good food, good atmosphere, great people,
and yeah, I'm loving it.
A meal like this just makes me so happy,
and just like gives me so much energy.
So, I'm gonna go ahead and
end the video right here.
Please remember to click
like, click thumbs up.
Thank you very much for watching,
and also, if you're
not already subscribed,
subscribe now for lots more
food and travel videos.
Thank you again for watching
and I will see you on the next video.
Goodbye from Manila.